welcome to another one of my Sadler's
honest book reviews in which I look at
literature dealing with philosophy
ethics leadership self-help and life
generally today I'm going to be talking
about a book that's new but isn't really
new it's how to die an ancient guide to
the end of life which is by Seneca but
edited translated and introduced by
James s ROM and published by Princeton
University Press this is a set of
selections from Seneca that all have to
do with death and I recommend it I think
that anybody who wants to have those
passages that are particularly oriented
towards thinking about the nature of
death and its importance for us as human
beings could benefit from having this
I always like to begin by talking about
3 s's that is the style of the work the
structure and giving a brief summary and
I'm going to do that last one first here
so as I mentioned this is a set of
selections and they're all focused on
the theme of death
so to summarize that this is Seneca
talking about something that he
underwent as a matter of fact it ends
talking about Seneca zone death
unfortunately having to kill himself at
the command of the Emperor Nero and it's
a topic that of course all of us are
going to have to face at one time or
another so that's a good segue then into
talking about the second one which is
the structure of the work and this is a
fairly short book altogether it is just
229 pages but you know small pages and
there are five main sections to the to
the book not including the the materials
at the end each of them is a chapter
consisting of a number of different
passages from Seneca some of them very
short some of them quite long each of
them with a little bit of introductory
material by the editor and translator of
this work so there's there's five
sections the first is prepare yourself
for of course dying the second have no
fear the third have no regrets the
fourth set yourself free the fifth
become part of the whole and then
there's an epilogue practice what you
preach and then you know I mentioned
that the book itself is you know over
200 pages long but the book really only
runs to page 122 because after that it's
Latin texts and the notes which you know
I think some of the readers may be
interested in the notes
very few readers are actually going to
look at the Latin texts but I suppose
it's nice to have them in there there is
a a good introduction at the start by
the editor and entry
later he gives a bio of Seneca if you
haven't you know encounter that already
that's that's useful to have he talks a
little bit about Seneca and stoicism and
does a bit of compare contrast between
Seneca and the other snoke so I think
that material is quite useful as well
when it comes to style we're talking
about translation and so I think it's
probably good to say this is a very
readable translation I think this will
be quite useful for the average person
encountering Seneca you are getting you
know short snippets so you're not
getting full discussions on the part of
Seneca but it's trying to zero in on
some of the main ideas
so what are the main ideas of the work
again this is Seneca so we're getting
Senecas
key ideas with respect to dyeing and
with respect to how we ought to live in
relation to death one of the key themes
is that death is ultimately unavoidable
and you might say well that's a
no-brainer who needs a book to know that
it's something that we often do forget
death and dissolution is inevitable for
all things whether we're talking about
human beings or our surroundings any of
the books we might pick they're all
going to die in their own way so that's
that's one key theme another that's
being treated in the second section is
that death is not the evil that we
typically not just think it to be but
fear it to be and the Stoics spent a lot
of time talking about how to properly
understand death and how to approach it
emotionally so that is another thing
that Seneca is going to talk about
another key theme is that if we think
about death and we do so in a very
realistic way without allowing our
emotions to overtake us without buying
into cultural assumptions that might be
rather questionable but instead putting
them to the test and analyzing them we
can live our lives in a better way so
you could see this as in some respects
not just about how not to feel bad about
death but how to live well you know it's
how to die but the subtitle an ancient
guide to the end of life but it could be
about the rest of our life as well
because we don't know when we're going
to die we don't know what the end of our
life is unless you know we're being
executed or have some sort of disease
that leads to that another key idea that
is particularly interesting given
Senecas own history is that death is an
escape and it's an escape from what
becomes intolerable for a rational be
which could include being bossed around
by a tyrant which is in fact the case
for poor Seneca dealing with Nero he was
an advisor to Nero tried to keep him on
a straight track was very unsuccessful
in doing so there's also a really good
discussion about whether suicide is
legitimate or not the Stoics I won't say
had mixed feelings about this but they
didn't see every single suicide as
legitimate but they did think that that
somebody like Cato who you know is not
that long before Seneca legitimately
committed suicide so there's there's
some some interesting discussion of that
and I'm actually going to read you one
one little passage from the text that
brings a few of these themes together
again this is Senecas own words it's not
death that's glorious but dying
courageously no wooden praises death
rather we praise the person who sold
death stripped away before causing at
any turmoil the death that was glorious
in Cato's case was based and worthy of
shame in Deccan Moses
this is dekha most the man who while
seeking postponement of death though
destined to die drew apart in order to
empty his bowels and when summoned to
his death in order to bear his neck said
I'll bear it if I can live what madness
to take flight when there's no going
backward I'll bear it if I can live he
almost added even under Antony that's a
man worthy to be allowed to live alright
he says so he says as I was discussing
earlier see that death is in itself is
neither good nor bad Cato made the most
honorable use of a dekha most the most
shameful so the idea here is that
suicide and and death in general is what
we make of it and that is another key
idea of the Stoics that Seneca discusses
at great length something else that the
the editor brings out that I think is
quite interesting I hadn't thought about
this beforehand is that Seneca himself
more than the other Stoics really does
talk about death really focuses on it
and you might say well
maybe that's a function of the time that
he lived in you know under these these
despots who are Caesars quite arbitrary
and capricious you know all sorts of
shenanigans going on you know that
there's there's a possibility to that I
don't know that there is less of that
going on in Epictetus world or in Marcus
Aurelius or in you know any of the other
Stoics that we might might run across at
least in part but it is clearly the case
that Seneca did a lot more writing about
it not necessarily more thinking but a
lot more writing than many of the other
stoic so I think that's a great point
that Rahm is is making here
what are the good points about this work
I think there's quite a few and I'm
happy to say what they are the first is
that this is going to be a really good
intro for somebody who hasn't read
Seneca but is interested in stoic
philosophy and I think it's a it's a
great theme it'll help people at least
if they don't agree with Seneca and put
things in perspective in a stoic way
they can at least see what the Stoics
had to say including this major stoic
thinker about the condition that we're
all in and the inevitable death that we
must face so it's a good intro for
Senecas work
it's definitely by somebody who knows
Senecas work inside and out I was you
know very happy to read the translations
I think they really are quite quite
excellent they're gonna be very readable
for the the modern person there's not a
lot of these and thou in there anything
along those lines
it's organised I think in a very useful
way to use five chapters bringing
together these passages quite a good way
to do it he could have touched on more
but then it would have been a longer
book and maybe this is exactly the right
sort of length for the English portion
of the book and the last thing that I'll
say that I really do like about it is
when you're excerpting from an author
it's it's very difficult to decide what
to include and what to leave out and the
tendency is always to try to pack as
much in as possible
rom has selected I think some of the
best passages for conveying Senecas own
views now there's there's more to Seneca
of course than is in here but you can
always go to the other works you can
read the whole letters or read you know
the consolations or read whatever you
want the various treatise by Seneca but
this is good
provide you with an excellent entry
point into thinking about it yeah it's
nice the way that these are gathered
together so that that you can think
primarily about this issue of death
the only negative thing that I do have
to say about this work there's always
some sort of fly in the ointment isn't
there is interestingly something that I
imagine many readers are going to see as
a positive and that's the Latin texts
that are included because if you look at
the book this much of it is latin texts
and so it could have been a much thinner
volume I don't think that adding the
Latin text at the end really does any
good it's not as if scholars are going
to go through this and say oh I'm going
to check his translation I better go to
the the Latin and you know it's not
particularly convenient because it's not
facing pages you got to go back and
forth and the ordinary person are they
going to be reading the Latin I highly
doubt it so you know it just added some
some pages and made the book a bit
thicker so it won't fit so nicely say in
your back pocket but that's a very minor
minor quibble isn't it with with a book
that otherwise is quite good
so to sum up do I recommend this work
definitely and I think this is a great
entry point for anybody who hasn't read
Seneca it's going to be like I mentioned
a very readable translation and
collection of his stuff you're not going
to find anything in here that's not in
other texts that that are available but
it's bringing together these discussions
about death so if you're interested in
that particular topic
I think this book is for you
you